[Music]
everybody now is talking about the pope
well one network has already taken
advantage of the pope's newfound
popularity and they developed this brand
new show it's very exciting let's take a
look
two identical twin boys separated at
birth
one grew up in brooklyn hey i'm vinnie
from brooklyn
and the other grew up in italy and
became pope arma the pulp
when these two twins reunite
accidentally hey i look like you and i
look like you
things get pretty crazy
hey give him the beverage
[Music]
hey he's not the pope i'm the pope who's
the pope coming this fall somewhere
maybe
hey bro let's go pick up some chicks huh
but i'm a celibate these are driving me
crazy
wow that's uh
[Music]
that's an awful show
it's a piece of crap we should look at
things before we play them
that would mean coming in before the
show airs yeah
let's cut into both of our now time i
think i feel like we all discovered
something together
that was a piece of [ __ ]
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
oh well our checks come either way
[Applause]
thank you don't cheer that
don't applaud that that's awful
we're gonna try harder next time sure we
will